chapter 7.
different costumes same eye
hmm
how do we uh
I mean it's a great continuation from
the last one yeah
um and first I'll just kind of set the
stage by saying that it's a stage yes
um it's like like a play that you would
go to you know all the characters you
know you have your your mom your dad you
have the tree you have the wind
sometimes you know they actually have
characters playing the win
um
all of those beings
are actual people so like they have
names on stage but they're actually
people like if you go approach them
later they won't talk to you about their
stage name they'll tell you who they are
yeah and that's important
yeah softball that over yeah
right right
um yeah that I mean they're telling us
who they truly are but there's something
on stage though they're playing a
character yes and that's this is so
foundational to the book to the course
to self-inquiry is you have like we've
said you have play you have characters
you have costumes you have identities
and you have I behind all of that and so
when you're tuned into okay different
costumes same eye and that I can forget
itself as the costume identity
it can remember itself through like the
costume identity yes
yes and then it can be the costume from
the knowledge
and then it looks at its other costumes
and it sees I behind those other
costumes man and it just comes from that
knowledge
so it comes from Love and for
timelessness and I like what she says
like arguably to to discover I you need
the costume yes it's like to discover I
you need the illusion nice how would I
know
you know
um and I like this quote as it being
arguably the most important uh future
reality is the ability to forget and
remember yeah that's at chapter seven
we're explaining God yes
we're explaining God in the same
sentence as you
you have the ability to forget and
remember you can choose bondage yeah you
can choose bondage just like you can
choose Freedom you know this is actually
one of my favorite ways when I talk to
people because people ask me about
what's going on
and it's so at when they ask I now that
I've gained a new level of Mastery I'll
reflect to them
that either way
if you choose to stay in bondage stay an
illusion stay in suffering of separation
in only being your label
just as free and just as powerful if you
choose to remember I behind all costumes
and to let go of your suffering and let
go of all of the stories and lack and
separation and anxiety and depression
and that's equally as free of a choice
to go either and that's the art of Free
Will that's the art of sovereignty
that's the art of Being pure reflection
to them that either choice is free and
then from there they can choose freely
instead of yeah yeah
between them
yeah man
I I I have nothing to say so
the ability to forget and remember man
he killed that I'm sorry
it's a cool feature
it's dope yeah and when we did our
conversation back in August of 2021 on
simulation
when we first launched the book
we
we were both so like in love with how
God I
can design reality
where there is the future to forget and
remember that is crazy
I can't even fathom that
like just to think about coming up with
that thought I'm saying I'm gonna put
this in the design yeah
like and then and then to say okay then
how would you form it so it it's it's
flawless
it's like Flawless like I mean in like
in the spiritual Community I would say
that we forget all the time everyone
forgets and it's like inevitable and you
just have the choice to remember when
you choose to I honestly want to say
we're more in forgetfulness than
remembering I mean like subconsciously
maybe it's the other way around but like
consciously like you know I don't go
around like oh I'm good I'm good I'm
good I'm good I'm good I'm good I'm good
no I don't perpetually yeah I'm I I'm I
this is I it's all I right I I I'm at
CVS or I'm driving my car I'm doing this
and that
um and then I remember or it Dawns on me
like wow we're all connected you know
it's like and so and I was talking to
Alice I was like you know that would
give me a headache man to constantly
know all the time or be like consciously
aware rather that I'm God I'm God I'm
God I'm all connected this is all there
is because it can get away it can get a
little because I'm I would say I'm right
now in the phase where I'm as I talk to
the Checker out person at CVS I you're
in that mind I'm in that mindset where I
where I speak and I sort of like try to
listen to the words that I say from the
uh other self I want you to say that one
more time do you speak like when I speak
I'm trying to be you listening to these
words simultaneously
and that can it can get very trippy and
it can get
um it's kind of nice to forget let's put
it that way but this is just to
highlight that though if you were to
stop the chorus after what he just said
and just really marinate on it that's
powerful it's really that's powerful to
really sit here and think and hear
yourself yes from another person's body
just you know that like I said we don't
we're not advocating to do it all the
time but just to have that those moments
it's powerful and it anchors you and I
and it anchors you in Awareness yes yeah
and then if you bring that to when you
talk to your wife your husband your
co-workers your friends
strangers
it will totally change because you will
no longer be trying to like force a
perspective or try to change someone or
try and manipulate because you'll know
that they are also I and that means they
are also you
and you as a unique expression and you
as a unique expression correct and then
that's where the greater Harmony the
greater love all that good stuff can
come and another important part to this
chapter that we were touching on a
little bit earlier is this quote Veil
which you could also say is like a
veilless veil
um
arguably being one of the most important
features of reality where it's the
ability to forget and remember as has
been talked about in Traditions it's
sort of like the front and back side of
your hand or another way to view it it's
like that very
that line which isn't even really a line
between the Shadow and the light yeah
when you see the way that a it's hitting
a tree and where the line is the ability
is that Middle Point yeah yeah and then
you just go either way but to have that
ability the ability is like riding that
middle ground The Sweet Spot that's what
they talk about in spirituality yeah
Sweet Spot man the middle way the middle
path yes yeah yeah because you don't you
don't want to overly indulge in illusion
and forgetting and you don't want to
overly indulge in oh I know that I'm
gone and we're running around saying
everyone is I and don't forget and all
this type of stuff yeah so I'm gonna
start selling subscriptions and courses
and all this type of stuff and making
that your identity yeah now you have a
new spiritual ego right I'm a guru you
listen to me yes yes I'm gonna have an
ashram everyone's gonna come to my
ashram which is
I don't know like I said in the
beginning of my past I love stuff like
that and now it's just like man that's
just kicking and watch the office go to
roscals
when I see your Temple bro
just know that the temple is inside it's
I yeah that's it that's it yeah
right beautiful this is chapter seven
that is chapter seven